let's go to our audience and hear from
some of you such an important week covid
recovery of mine the Herschel Walker
loss in Georgia and so many important
things I want to hear from you we take
calls via Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord and we are going to start today
with Chuck from Pennsylvania Chuck what
is on your mind today
uh can you hear me David I can loud and
clear my friend
all right cool uh yeah I just wanted to
say you know I I my faith in humanity or
the US has been slightly restored with
the uh the Walker loss has it really
though because he almost won you know
what I mean it's like I get I'm with you
in the sense that if we imagine in
America today with senator-elect
Herschel Walker and then we we say oh we
avoided that of course that that's good
but the guy almost won like that's
extraordinarily depressing
yeah yeah I mean it like you said it's
it's depressing at the same time because
I don't know how many he had like he got
like two million votes and and he only
won by like what was it 48 51 yeah the
split or something like that yeah but uh
anyway uh so yeah slightly but still
depressing
um but no it's sort of like a food for
thought or just like something that I've
thought about like
so you know how like the right
um they're they're against all the
electric car like any push for green
energy stuff like that yeah uh they want
to stick in their traditional ways
um so I've thought about like in you
know 50 100 years however many years I
don't know but do you see maybe like the
Republican Party becoming like the sort
of like a small group almost like the
Amish where they're kind of just shunned
because they're stuck in their ways and
uh like total technological luddites or
something yeah yeah yeah like just
they're still using their diesel trucks
and using Kohl's to burning coal for
energy in their small little community
and they're stuck in their religious
ways listen it's not impossible because
think about it you know they're against
all sorts of
um medical research that certainly is
going to lead to advancements and it's
totally plausible that they will sort of
shun taking availing themselves of some
of that we're seeing it with vaccines
already right they're all we see this
huge anti-backs in movement so they're
already self-selecting selecting out
there they seem to love just burning
gasoline in their vehicles for for
whatever reason and they consider it
manly and culturally relevant and
whatever else so maybe they will resist
that as well the way I think it might
happen is at a certain point it seems
the direction things are going is that
new vehicles sold will have to be
electric but like if you can keep an
existing
um if you can keep an existing uh ice
vehicle on the road then you can keep
driving it or something so it'll almost
it might become kind of like how in Cuba
because of the Embargo a lot of the cars
are really really old the American cars
and they just have to keep maintaining
them because that's what they have it
might end up being something sort of
like that
yeah yeah I mean you know they may end
up being forced with like the car thing
because once they get older you know
there won't be parts for the old ice and
they'll all be electric or something
like that but I mean even just as far as
like you what you were saying with like
medicine and stuff like I knew like the
Amish communities now like they don't go
to regular dentists and stuff like some
of them so like they all end up like
their teeth brought out and stuff so I
don't know it was just something I kind
of thought uh kind of like uh it's all I
see similarities sort of thing yeah I I
absolutely do and I don't think it would
become listen to become like the Amish
it's going to take a much much much
longer time
um but uh the idea of it I completely
understand
yeah that was all I had though all right
Chuck from Pittsburgh thank you
very powerful phone call I appreciate it
just as a reminder if you want to get on
to talk to me in the Discord your
nickname has to be your name and where
you're calling from or where you're
calling from and your name uh all of the
different nicknames that are in there
you are self-selecting out because it's
just not the right format very very
important to understand